tampa bay buccaneers all of a sudden are
the hottest team in the national
football league
five prime time games for a team that
no one wanted to watch a year ago but
for the
comedy slash tragedy that was the jameis
winston career that
that became compelling as the season
went on now the buccaneers are all about
excellence they've got tom brady they've
got grog they have optimism
and they have some interesting games and
again right out of the gates the nfl
pulling no punches big cat here we go
saints and bucks in new orleans week one
drew brees and tom brady combined ages
of 84 come september
that that is a great great game and of
course they play twice you've got aaron
rodgers and tom brady
coming up in week six of the season in
tampa bay when the packers go
to that's the old bay of pigs that's the
chris berman bay of pigs game
the buccaneers and the packers getting
together in tampa week six
nick falls possibly a rematch of super
bowl 52
if falls is the quarterback come week
five for the bears
jared goff and tom brady another super
bowl rematch
patrick mahomes week 12 going to tampa
bay for the chiefs and the buccaneers
kirk cousins week 14 how did that get on
there the last three
kirk cousins and matt ryan twice those
shouldn't be on there the rest yes
the uh remember the packers versus the
bucks
the warren sap verse was it mike sherman
to put a jersey on after the game the
hit on chad clifton that was a that was
an all-time
sound bite that was pre-social media era
uh i agree with you though this is gonna
be fun seeing tom brady play a lot of
teams and he didn't get to play you know
he played him once every four years
but now that he's in the nfc schedule
the fact he gets a play drew brees twice
the fact that he can play a lot of these
teams more than once every four years it
it's uh
it's gonna be cool it's gonna be a cool
wrinkle to the schedule and a lot of
good games out there
and we do need to leave matt ryan on
that graphic because it's two super bowl
rematches or two rematches of the same
super bowl
from the 28 to three game i mean that's
going to torment matt ryan all year
and he has to wait until week 15 for it
to happen
and that's one thing i don't like and i
understand it's impossible to avoid it
but when you have i don't know you may
feel differently about it than i do
when you have games between the same two
teams like
two weeks apart i don't like that spread
it out yeah i know
i love it it's impossible to do it i
know it's impossible to do it
so i just embrace it when it happens but
i'd like to see
tom brady and matt ryan get together
early in the year and late in the year
if possible but again with 256 games
it's gonna happen
but uh brady and ryan are gonna have to
wait a long time to see each other again
and i don't know maybe matt ryan would
rather
wait as long as possible to have to see
tom brady there's just a chance those
games aren't going to matter
because one of those two teams may be
out of it by the time we get to middle
of december
yeah i couldn't disagree with you more
mike uh i
love when the schedule has that wrinkle
where you play one of your division
rivals
uh two times in three weeks two times in
four weeks
as a fan you basically get yourself set
in this mode of
we're going to now play this team twice
let's get ready
and try to get two wins and i just it's
i
obviously i wouldn't like it if every
single division rival was bunched up
like that but having one team
that you play every year and it's in
that short span of three or four weeks
i like it it makes it adds a little
flavor a little something different to
the nfl schedule
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports